so the moral of the Thanksgiving story
is stuffing or dressing it really
doesn't matter and enjoy the day hi I'm
Angie and today we're gonna decide is
this stuffing or is it dressing so from
what I can tell in the south it's called
dressing maybe in the Midwest I can't be
sure but definitely in the south
it's called dressing and in the North
the Northeast and in the west coast
it's called stuffing even if it's not
actually put into the bird it's still
constant from what I can gather the only
difference in stuffing and dressing is
dressing is a bread mixture that goes
inside of a turkey and then it becomes
stuffing so dressing and stuffing are
essentially the same food but they're
utilized differently dressing is baked
in a pan outside of a turkey and
stuffing which is the same actual food
is stuffed inside of a turkey or chicken
I don't really understand too many
benefits of stuffing an actual turkey
but one thing I will say if you really
want to get a lot of flavor in the
stuffing then put it in the bird because
what happens is as the bird cooks all
the flavor and all the juices seep down
into that stuffing and just kind of give
it even more richness and more flavor so
that's I think that's the benefit of
actually stuffing the turkey one thing
to be very careful of is you want to
make certain that the stuffing is fully
heated and that's 165 degrees so just
because the turkeys cook that stuffing
is probably not cooked yet because the
heat has to go all the way through all
the protein through the bird and all the
way into the cavity where that stuffing
is and that's going to take a little bit
more time so one thing to keep in mind
is if you do not get the stuffing up to
165 degrees you're gonna run the risk of
getting food poisoning you want to be
mindful to put the stuffing properly
because some people can get food
poisoning from undercooked stuffing and
no one wants to spend their holiday in
the bathroom I would advise for the most
part keep
stepping out of the bird but if you
really really want to stuff that turkey
get a little one a smaller turkey is
just gonna take less time and obviously
the bigger trick you have the more
stuffing it needs the more timing I am
100% Pro dressing by the time this
stuffing has come to a safe temperature
to eat unfortunately sometimes the bird
gets dry so it's a very tricky dance of
having a juicy moist turkey and stuffing
that safe to eat so one way to avoid
this is just put the stuffing in a pan
and cook it separately so the moral of
the Thanksgiving story is stuffing or
dressing it really doesn't matter just
make something that you love and eat it
with people you love and enjoy that oh
yes